so we
uh
oh no oh
yeah she's back she's back she's back
she's back
let's check it out
hello guys let's get out here
cat here don't get there getting on
people
it's that time again it's 4
20 in the morning and i can't shoot man
oh snap yo this [ __ ] is smoking herb
son
i made it almost made it through that
time frame so i've been up for
i don't know since three
it's 4 20 now thank you for the update
oh she is smoking weed she really is
snap bro and i should mention the reason
why
i uh do the cannabis thing
it's mainly for three reasons
okay to make me cough on purpose oh yeah
that's why
we love i love coffee why would you want
to cough on purpose to cleanse bro
todd the nano poisons i got it
so i can clear my lungs and breathe
the uh by that's not how it works i
don't think the [ __ ]
rationalizing that people do
so they can do their chosen [ __ ]
drugs or their chosen vices
stop wasting energy
stop wasting all this energy trying to
rationalize
why you do something you enjoy i love to
smoke weed i smoke weed all the time
i've never in my life been like i have
to smoke weed if i don't
my chakras get all misaligned and then
like i can't
properly sleep if i don't have we yes
because you're addicted to weed
just say you know what because i like it
the problem is
is that this woman has been pissing and
moaning about how
owen benjamin's the reason her life is
so [ __ ] up right now
he's the reason not all the decisions
you make i can't afford to stay in a
room i'm living in my car but i have
weed money
like these are the kind of things that
make me not have any empathy for people
just you know if there's dudes right now
like that david guy
you could go like hey man like you know
like you think that david guy [ __ ]
that he's living in the streets
he's probably like man i'm good i had a
sandwich early i got an ice cold beer
i'm gonna go out try to get some more
money for beer any kind like you know
what i mean
but like he's not going around going oh
i'm in this situation because of some
guy on youtube it's his fault that i've
made this series of decisions you know
what kind of sandwich i like
any kind of turkey oh that would be
funny
that's the only thing he's very specific
about i don't eat that ham
[ __ ] get this fork
people don't understand this that's a
good thing
it's uh expectorant is that like a harry
potter
thing or i don't know she's probably
quoting from the necromanomicon
i got it it makes you cough it makes you
cough
it's not that word it's actually a
different word but
anyway i can't wait to see if getting
high
makes the list of reasons
i don't think so here guys let me do
what she's doing but i'll be more honest
with you hey mike why is it you smoke
weed
so it gets me high and that's it life is
unbearable lately got it you go oh well
that makes sense
i like to make myself cough
it is that though because you're
expelling
um the mucus and the fl whatever you
your fluids and stuff that you don't
need and it carries away
all the toxins and stuff okay and if
you're wearing a mask
you breathe out those toxins you breathe
in
we should be getting fresh air but we're
not you know what else
you know what else cleans out your
system a nice cup of
hot coffee a nice cup oh no but oh no i
know you've dipped the toxins in the
coffee just
hot chocolate tea how about this
just hot water with lemon these are all
any hot liquid
you can drink enough of it and you'll
start coughing up everything like that's
literally why
they tell you when you're sick to go
have some hot tea
or have a hot cup of water with lemon
because it just
and everything comes out but you know
you want weed and i know just
smoke you weed but you you get air in
you
and it filters it goes through your body
out in your lungs and everything and
then you breathe out
and with it all that toxins come out and
then if you have a mask on stopping it
and blocking it
you're breathing back your own toxins
repeatedly
repeatedly repeatedly every single
minute that you're breathing skipping
out here those
freaking cops in standpoint
took mine and then somebody that offered
me help
on here offered you drugs it's kind of
disappeared now i guess
probably because you threw away the 50
mcdonald's card they gave you
yeah or maybe it was just one of the
trolls [ __ ] with you
that's true you know like there's a
million reasons why but also
you probably shouldn't be relying on one
person on you like you know what i mean
like
you can't just rely on random youtube
folks to bail you out of a jam
was claiming to be a bear but he works
for the sheriff's department or that's
where he sent me
telling them telling me if you listen to
this
i don't know i don't know if i should
say your name or not i won't say
it but led me he led me to the
he to offer me a place to stay on a farm
in sandpoint
and he sent her to the sheriff's
department i think that's what happened
yeah
then he uh
we emailed back and forth
and he said we could meet like in a
public place
he was wanting my services for him and
his family
they're into healing and uh would pay me
you know very well to do massage and
i don't know maybe do haircuts or
whatever they want
um not whatever they jack of all trades
this lady
or something i mean i do have limits and
boundaries and stuff
but then he um
i get this email from saying to just
meet him at the sheriff's department
like he works at the sheriff's
department i don't know it started to
sound like some kind of setup
what gave it away lady the sheriff's
department part
come on lady oh
[ __ ] i'm sorry
oh but i
i know the sheriffs are better than the
cops
i don't know about here there's a lot of
things in idaho i don't like
probably the only thing i do like is the
potatoes
idaho does have good potatoes yeah i
mean but other places do too
yeah it's true like like some places
make good potatoes
and also have other cool things you know
you live in other cities and have
potatoes from idaho anyway yeah
you know they have these things called
trucks yeah they bring them right over
on the truck
the rest of them are a bunch of spud
heads
i didn't think she was going to be so
naughty i thought you said you liked the
potatoes now obviously you don't like
the potatoes
geez make up your mind with the potatoes
oh i love the potatoes by the way you're
a bunch of spud heads well i'm sorry but
i i'm gonna guess that's a compliment
based on your prior statement about
potatoes
from hollywood and new york and
california and all around
all these uh millionaires are
rich snobs here with their
attitude in idaho yeah look i'll be
honest royce
you know i like to consider myself
well-traveled
uh and i will say that the people of
idaho they really think who the [ __ ]
they are
you go you go to sam point idaho and i
mean everybody there really puts on airs
they really are [ __ ] highfalutin
they're holier than thou imagine going
into a diner
full of a bunch of farmers just having a
nice little lunch
millionaires and you're like hey oh oh i
get you all think you're better than me
and they're all just quietly eating like
i don't know who this man is what is
this person doing
i just wanted a nice cup of coffee oh
it's just disgusting
oh man there's just so much we're in now
they're doing [ __ ] like i bought a pair
of
kodiak boots kodiak did you hear
that kodiak no okay i got a
i don't think a um a registered
corporation heard you i don't i doubt it
pair of kodiak boots a person will know
who i'm talking to
and uh they're like 200 boots and i
don't ever spend that kind of money on
myself because i don't have it
well they were on sale for like going
i don't know whatever so you're living
in your car you're homeless you're
having issues eating food
and you're spending money on kodiak
boots yeah dude it's never a bad time
for new boot goofing
oh you're right yeah all right even if
you're living in your car in the snow
gotta be new boot goofing three payments
tell her
tell her i'll say she's like i should
contact and go like i'll send you money
but you gotta do the new boot goofy
sketch
that's fair
being 170 with the tax
wait the boots were 100 but ended up
being 170 with the tax
i mean i don't know well okay
but i think she may have the tax rate in
idaho incorrect
i don't think it's seventy dollars for a
hundred dollar purchase
look let me ask you something are you
certain
it's a 70 tax rate i didn't ask
i asked are you certain with a 100
certainly do you know for a fact that
the sales tax in idaho isn't 70
no i mean of course she's there i know
you're right i guess i get only
physically that's fair i don't know but
gotta trust the size i'm gonna doubt
that it's not a 70 tax rate i'm using
i'm using covid logic
i got to trust the experts royce she's
there okay
okay i mean fair enough like when we
used to have to trust the nurses when
they were like
no no no we're overrun it's like 28 days
later in this hospital
and then it turned out they were making
tick-tock videos and showing the titties
on reddit
but we had to believe them royce because
they were there and we weren't
the sales tax in sandpoint items so low
is six percent
so it should have been well below the
national average six dollars
[Laughter]
and uh they
the first thing i should have been well
the boot
the leather thing that whole little they
were leather boots so
that's all i get and they were salt
resistant and everything and i needed
boots to keep my
feet warm i did not have warm shoes or
boots
and i was getting that frostbite thing
my toe feels better now that i've been
in the warmth
but you got weed that's the thing i'm
always thinking about too it's like
you were able to afford weed though
like i've in the past made
sacrifices for addiction right
and i see people do it all the time and
i try not to judge people right
you do what you got to do okay nobody
can tell another person
like hey i know what you need right so
maybe you know who knows maybe you do
need weed to cope
with life i don't know it's not my
business right and i don't care if you
go look man i didn't uh
you know i i didn't pay my credit card
this month because i got weed and you go
all right well that's
you want to pay interest on that you
that's your thing you want to stay maxed
out that's fine that's your business
right
but don't make excuses for other [ __ ]
like don't
don't have money for weed and then leave
your house behind and not pay your bills
but then tell me that you're living in a
car and it's owen benjamin's fault
like that's the [ __ ] i can't stand i
don't look down on people from making
bad decisions we've all done it
we all will do it in the future but you
do it and you live with it
and you go okay this is my bed i've made
it i'm gonna lay in it
but this lady is just like everything
bad that happens to me is owen's fault
and by the way isn't it owens community
that you're now grifting off of
yes correct so shouldn't you be a little
grateful for that
i when we got on about the manager
because i was telling her to call her
and everything and
she wouldn't and uh
so i'm like toxins are coming out she's
getting the toxins out stuck with these
boots
and so she tried to return the boots she
said to me
at the end of the thing and that's when
i just just [ __ ] laughed
she stayed well then you probably wore
them you walked around in the snow and
the salt and the sleep and then got
[ __ ] up
and then they probably you're probably a
gross smelly 69 year old homeless lady
who's babbling smells like weed and is a
[ __ ] mess and lives in your car
and you came back and went i wanna
return boats and they were like these
boots are destroyed lady
they've been on your disgusting feet
nobody wants to i can't now
restock these and get the money for them
like
you know like you bring something back
you're supposed to bring it back in good
shape
and go like hey this didn't fit or
whatever
manager won't return them either so she
was gonna have me stay there until
monday
this was last week so it
cost me you know like it was gonna cost
me two three
two more days of staying at you know or
whatever
just because of that so i leave with
them i'm still wearing them but
i have to keep you make sure that that
thing's out of way i'm going to have to
try to
i don't know if i should cut it out or
staple it or whatever if you staple it
you're definitely not going to take them
back
yeah but is it still covered under
warranty and made alterations
by the way uh tampered goods has a good
line he says she's an energy vampire i
i used to hear that term all the time
except it was psychic vampire but it's
the same
yeah psychic vampire is the same thing
it's just it's people
who will just just
suck the energy and everybody's [ __ ]
happiness out of the room it's
they really are like a black hole of
psychic energy where
they just if you're around them all of a
sudden you find yourself being like and
this isn't
fair so and then you're like you're it's
because you're around this person
they're literally draining you
of your good energy and just you end up
being miserable and guess what they're a
black hole
they never get happier it's it really is
[ __ ] crazy dude
um well i have t-mobile they've been the
best
thing you know i've had been with them
for 17 years now
i'm going to kill myself routine yeah
but with her was probably real
one but as far as the internet companies
go
they are screwing people all the time
and then try to call them to talk about
it and you can't get through
tell me you don't sit there and go
through a run around router in your car
that's what i'm trying to understand
[ __ ] 2009 honda civic has a router in
it so here we go this now we get a
little better here
it's nonsense going on i mean it's
really happening
they're doing it being it's being done
to us
i just have because i eat so well and i
detox and i
fast and i live in my car and i have
frostbite and i drove into a ditch
and i moved from california to idaho
because um
somebody from sullivan's and son lives
there in the woods
and because i am pushed him at the post
office and because he thought i had a
gun
and because even after all of that even
though i'm a pothead who lives in a car
i'm still too good to eat mcdonald's
that's what he offered me for free out
of the kindness of their heart
and keep myself clean and pure which
clears up your third eye your pineal
gland
actually starts to decrest and break
down
and then you can see things yes that's
how we should be but people are
polluting themselves what if what if and
this is just a thought lady what if
you're
suffering from a combination of
psychosis borderline personality
disorder and now malnourishment
and that maybe the things you're seeing
aren't real see
i could imagine living in your car in
the wintertime in the cold not having
food and being all stoned
and being alone for days on end and not
having anything to do
and then giving yourself all you taking
all these weird supplements instead of
eating food
maybe just maybe you're going [ __ ]
crazy
that's the nuggies but she doesn't eat
the nuggies
well the even thinking about eating
nuggies is affecting her the nuggies
would be the healthiest thing this woman
does
any sort of food would be great for her
right now yeah
to the max as they talk about
drug addicts when they're a drug addict
you have to realize that the food
they're serving up to you
is poison this is the thing that i think
is funny they talk about drug addicts
when they're the drug addicts and she's
saying but
i i love and again look i don't smoke
weed anymore i stopped for over a year
now but
i did a lot i mean i smoked a lot of
weed okay i've been very clear about
that i have and i have no issue with
weed
i have no [ __ ] problem with it i
honestly think it should be legalized i
have no problem with it
but i hate people that smoke
[ __ ] a ton of wheat all day and go
[ __ ] drug addicts it's like you're
addicted to something in my case it's
food for example
everyone's addicted to something so
let's not [ __ ] pretend like you know
you're better
weeds actually medicine man no it's not
it's not medicine
if you take anything that has
psychoactive components in it
on a regular basis you are addicted to
it
that's if if you are if there's a thing
that you can take and it
provides you with some kind of an
altered state and you take that thing
every day you have an
addiction i don't care if it's like
literally like there's lesser drugs
there's caffeine there's
you know what i mean caffeine is a drug
and there are people that
pound energy drinks all [ __ ] day you
know and especially
ex-junkies like you'll see that [ __ ]
people that went to rehab
and they really did clean their life up
but boy are they gonna be
chimney-smoking cigarettes and pounding
bang energy drinks
that's how you can spot an addict by the
way the guy that always has coffee and a
cigarette you're like
that guy that guy used to do so much
cocaine
some of this stuff it here's there's
funguses
there's um insect parts even
there's um like forming insects like
their wings
and stuff like that you can actually see
that stuff
oh there was a god no you know he's
suffering from this that talks about it
but he's doing it to collect money from
everybody
she's talking about owen he's not giving
him any information he's not researching
it or anything so i can't count him but
you loved him
you loved him you drove all this way for
him to save to help him
you wanted to be with him and then he
said no and then all of his flaws were
suddenly apparent right there in front
of your eyes
you [ __ ] hypocrite but my friend
[ __ ] psycho hire these [ __ ] people
on the internet man
in switzerland then there's uh
michelle in mexico and uh
santos is starting to learn about this
are these people in your head or are
they real
that's the you start quite at this point
you start questioning that stuff are
these people are these
real people are in their in their head
he doesn't talk about the nano yet but
they're working on the healing aspects
uh
a guy almost died
was just blown up and turned black and
everything in the
the doctors and the hospital they just
rejected him and wouldn't help him so
he somehow he figured out how to build
the machine to
counter it and he's still alive today
watch uh
it's in santos benachi's uh video from
i don't know probably a month or two ago
it's in it it's the healing place in uh
i'm starting to think he might be gay
well hold on
back up here out of that i was
this is her 20 years ahead of people
really and people don't want to listen
to me they'd rather listen to a 40 year
old idiot
from hollywood that just likes to crack
jokes at people's expense but you listen
talk you you listen you built your whole
life around him
and then you got rejected and now you're
crying about it and now
now he's evil again man this is
not only with this woman but in general
this is a problem that is
like propagating itself on the internet
it's
it's there's not enough people that are
going out anymore there's not enough
people that have
real life friends and real life
communities are a part of
everybody's sitting on the internet all
day and everybody gets these
so many weird people that get these
[ __ ] stalkers and the minute you go
hey look please you just dial it back
you're making people uncomfortable
then they melt down they freak out and
then they just
dedicate their entire life to taking you
down and it's like
but you loved this person a week ago by
the way ralph in the chat says yes let's
listen to a homeless junkie about hope
yes she doesn't eat mcdonald's talks
about dicks and penises and anuses all
the time no wonder
i'm starting to think he might be gay
somebody i'm bisexual i guess all right
so you drove all the way out to
sandpoint idaho to
swear you're fealty to a gay guy
bisexual to bisexual uh
uh weirdo it seems like you're the [ __ ]
this is like when a woman goes
you have my baby daddy he's a [ __ ]
loser and it's like okay so you're the
one that let him come in you
and then decided to keep the baby but no
you're right he's the loser
maybe he's not uh practicing that right
now because he's holier than thou
you hear my prose coming out
or why i write in prose i'm a poetist i
write poetry she is i think she's a
poetist what the [ __ ] is a poetist
a poetist i can't find my books
and stuff i was thinking of heading back
to
western washington where my stuff is in
storage
people say go back home back home to
where to what
i surrendered the property i was
in in birch bay washington just north of
where gig harbor where owen left see how
close we were there
wow dude this is psychotic talk
wow we were so close i was so close to
him
i hope he's legitimately getting a
[ __ ] restraining order
he should because this is legit
restraining order type [ __ ] now
and how close we were here here in sand
when i was in sand point i'm in coeur
d'alene right now
so i'm heading to idaho today to get my
medicine
so i forgot what i was talking about and
it was important
don't know oh no oh no oh no by the way
your medicine that we're probably paying
for
of course you're paying for what's she
paying for she's buying boots yeah
you're buying boots and weed
but you got we got to pay for your
medicine right
ah shoot well
okay then i'll just end it here anyway
so
uh i'll see you soon frisbee said she's
visiting red ice next
henrik has to go out with a [ __ ] with
a 22 rifle
pleased to be getting off my property
i will be shooting you very soon with
what i talked about
on the next video i hope everyone is
well
and healthy consider what you're
sticking
in your friggin pie hole so you know
what you're doing
to yourself i'm getting mcdonald's
tonight despite this woman i just went
food shopping and i've been very good
lately about cooking
i'm getting some nuggies tonight just
despite this woman
that's going to be on you and the more
nana you
have in you the more they can take you
down because they they are controlling
us
through this what's that you can bet on
it
the nanobots remember she was talking
about the nanobots that are
nana inside of us was being haunted by
the ghost of anthony comey
he's alive there are machine there's
machinery going
on in you how what do you think the
transhumanism is
it's you're they're making us people
into robots
please wake up and smell the coffee well
i don't drink coffee because of all the
i won't put that filth on my body i
won't i will not put that filth
in my body sorry lady i uh i only drink
i only eat health burritos and smoke pot
in my car
as lady man jesus